versailles comme vous ne l'avez jamais
vu ce premier week-end de mars la france
retrouvera ses portes celle de france
miniature à elancourt 117 monument du
patrimoine français reproduit au 1 30e
réalisée en résine pvc ou même enfer
pour la tour eiffel elle émerveille
chaque année les deux cent mille
visiteurs
quand j'étais tout petit petit mais
j'étais venu d'angers de vagues
souvenirs mais je sonnais g c'était bien
culturellement spot se balader en france
de découvrir les monuments historiques
ont en france on a envie de lui c'est à
la france
voyager vraiment parce que je
connaissais certains des sites mais dans
la plupart et on se rend compte combien
cet hiver je trouve que c'est une
merveille les les monuments sont
vraiment magnifiques
cette année le parc réserve une
nouveauté de taille c'est la cité
médiévale de carcassonne qui va devenir
une des plus grandes maquettes du parc
150 m² et pour tout à fait bien
représenté cette cité médiévale inscrite
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco le
chantier a déjà commencé
les remparts devrait être installé pour
avril et les travaux terminés femme est
coût de la réalisation 80000 euros et si
les monuments font le bonheur des plus
grands les huit attractions font la joie
des plus petits le grand toboggan
la grande balançoires et c'est ce qui
déçoit et qui monte
on était là paris est comme un vieux mas
moi j'ai vu les voitures
prochain rendez-vous de france miniature
à ne pas manquer l'atelier chocolat à
pâques et la démonstration d'un parcours
d'agilité équestre en avril ne laissez
pas le train partir sans vous